So what if I told you that the productivity tool that's, you know, making you 50 percent faster at your job today is actually actively destroying your ability to do your job tomorrow?
I mean, that is a terrifying thought.
Yeah.
But you've probably felt it before, right?
Oh, definitely. It's like that superpower feeling when you go to the gym and you use one of those assisted pull up machines. Right. Yeah. The machine just like takes off half your body weight and suddenly you're doing sets of 10, 12, maybe 15 reps. You're just absolutely flying.
Right. But there is always that moment of truth when you step off the machine.
Exactly. You grab a regular bar, try to pull your actual unassisted body weight up.
And that is the exact moment you find out if you were actually building muscle or if the machine was just doing all the heavy lifting for you while you just went along for the ride.
Yeah. And that's exactly what we're doing in this deep dive today. We are sifting through a really fascinating stack of research to figure out if artificial intelligence is, well, acting like that assisted pull-up machine for our brains.
Basically asking, does AI actually build human expertise or does it erode it?
Right. Because raising your measured performance on a Tuesday and actually building deep, lasting human expertise over a decade, those turn out to be two entirely different objectives. And today we're going to see exactly where they pull apart.
Yeah. And to do that, we're bringing in a few background sources. But our anchor today is this massive brand new working paper. It just came out in September 2026.
Brand new.
Yeah. It's by David Autor from MIT, along with six co-authors from Google. And they really wanted to see what happens to highly skilled professionals when they use generative AI over a prolonged period.
Okay, so let's unpack this spine of the deep dive right up front. What they found is this profound paradox, right? AI made everyone at Urza's work better and it helped the juniors the absolute most. Initially. But, and this is the crazy part, after three months, only the senior lawyers
had become better at the job without the AI. So in short, the largest gains from AI accrued to the exact people who retained the least.
It's wild. But to understand why that happened, kind of have a look at the theory this paper was testing. Prior to this, the prevailing wisdom in economics was something called the leveling story.
Okay, the leveling story.
Yeah. This was established by a couple of major studies, one by Noi and Zhang in 2023, and another by Brynjolfsson, Lai, and Raymond in 2025.
Oh, I remember those. They looked at things like basic writing tasks and customer support reps, right?
Exactly. And they found a very consistent pattern. AI compresses the gap between novices and experts. It acts as this great equalizer because it boosts the low performers the most, basically bringing their work up to the level of these seasoned veterans.
Right, which sounds great.
It does. But the Otter team looked at that and asked, well, does this leveling theory hold up in highly technical, incredibly high stakes work? Because, you know, patent law is a totally different beast than basic customer service.
Yeah, it's arguably one of the most technical forms of law in existence. So they set up this pre-registered randomized trial. They took 133 practicing patent lawyers across 11 different US intellectual property firms.
And it's worth noting, all these firms already do patent work for Google.
So these are top tier professionals. Right.
And they randomized them two to one into a treatment group, stratified by their firm and their seniority. And they defined a senior lawyer as having seven or more years of experience.
Okay, so two-thirds get the treatment. What exactly was the treatment?
They got access to a tool called Inflow. It's an unreleased Google Labs writing assistant.
Oh, so it's not just ChatGPT.
No, no. It's highly specialized. It has AI typing, inline text modification, a critique function, and you can even chat with different AI personas.
Wait, like make it act like a specific person?
Exactly. You can ask it to act like a harsh editor or a technical expert or even a patent examiner. And meanwhile, the control group, they just kept doing their jobs the old-fashioned way, no generative AI at all.
OK, so they let them work and they do these initial assessments, right? A drafting task at 10 days and then a much harder drafting task at 90 days. And initially it looks like that leveling theory is just absolutely bulletproof.
It really does. While the AI is turned on and actively being used, it perfectly confirms the background theory. Overall, drafting scores jumped a massive 0.34 standard deviations at 10 days and 0.38 at 90 days.
But it's eyes at the distribution that's so crazy.
Yeah. The juniors gained about 0.58 to 0.60 standard deviations. The seniors only gained about 0.22 to 0.30.
So the juniors with the AI were suddenly drafting just as well and about as fast as the unassisted seniors. But I think we need to clarify where those gains came from.
Right. It wasn't magic.
No, the AI wasn't producing like sudden moments of sheer genius. What it did was ruthlessly raise the floor. It avoided bad bottom quintile work. It's kind of like bumper bowling.
Oh, that's a good way to put it.
Yeah, the AI isn't necessarily throwing strikes for you, but it's completely blocking the gutters. You literally can't roll a zero.
That is exactly what the data shows. The AI clearly elevates the immediate work product. But, you know, what happens to the human brain driving the process? That leads directly to the 90-day unassisted test.
This is where it gets so clever. At 90 days, they gave everyone a redlining task. So they had to take a flawed AI-generated patent draft and mark it up. But the catch is they had to do it completely without AI.
No inflow, no chat bots, nothing. And this is the cleverest part of the study, because redlining a document isolates the professional judgment that the lawyer has internalized in their own brain, completely separate from what a tool can just generate for them.
Right. And they had independent, blinded attorneys at an outside firm score the work. They looked at five dimensions, enforceability, technical accuracy, completeness, clarity, and my personal favorite, strategic ambiguity.
Such a great term.
Can you actually explain that for the listener? Because strategic ambiguity kind of sounds like an oxymoron. Like, why would a lawyer actively try to be ambiguous?
Well, it's actually a hallmark of true legal expertise. In patent law, you don't want to define an invention so narrowly that a competitor can just change like one tiny screw and completely bypass your patent.
Oh, right. They just steal the idea with a technicality.
Exactly. So you want to use broad, deliberately flexible claim language. The goal is to maximize the future enforcement scope of the patent while still meeting the strict standards to get it approved. Striking that balance requires a masterful touch.
Okay, so the independent graders are looking for that high-level thinking on this unassisted test, and the results just completely extend and complicate the leveling theory.
They really do, because it shows the leveling effect does not carry over to unassisted work. Overall, unassisted redlining scores went up 0.32 standard deviations. but it was entirely driven by the seniors.
The seniors jumped 0.45.
Right, and the juniors. Zero average gain, actually negative 0.03.
But it wasn't just that the juniors stayed stagnant, right? The paper talks about this fascinating nuance. Their scores bifurcated. So there were far fewer mediocre scores, but significantly more poor scores, offset by a few more good ones. It's
like some juniors actually learned, but some were actively hurt by the AI. And the paper admits it can't say exactly why.
Right. Statistically, it's a bit of a black box.
But wait, here's where it gets really interesting to me. I'm going to push back a bit. The juniors who experience the biggest jump in output quality while using AI, the ones looking at A-level work every day, they are the ones who internalize the least. How is that even
possible?
Well, to answer that, we have to look past the spreadsheets and look at the qualitative texture of the study. Like, what were they actually doing? Right. The treated seniors, they approached the redlining task by looking at the macro picture. They restructured whole sections of the flawed patent.
And when they made a structural edit, they annotated it with the foundational legal principles behind it.
Okay. And what did the juniors do?
They worked completely sequentially, just top-down, minor stylistic edits. And because they got bogged down in the minutia, they literally ran out of time before they even reached the most important part, the claims. Oh, wow. Yeah. And the researchers noted that juniors would leave comments
in the margins like, the claims use indefinite language, without actually rewriting the language to fix it.
Wait, they diagnosed it, but they didn't execute the fix. That note sounds exactly like a prompt you would feed into an AI chat bot to make it do the work for you. Exactly. Except the AI wasn't there to execute it. So did the AI cause this bad habit?
Because they were basically treating the paper like a prompt bot.
That's a great question, but the researchers clarified a vital distinction here. The control group juniors, the ones who never touched the AI, they did this exact same thing.
Oh, really?
Yeah. So the AI didn't cause this diagnose without execute habit. It just utterly failed to fix it.
That's wild. It's like if you use GPS to drive around a new city. When you use it, your output is perfect. You get there super fast. But if your phone dies after three months, you realize you haven't built a mental map of the streets at all. You were just following directions.
That's a perfect analogy. The seniors already had the map. They just used GPS to avoid traffic. The juniors never built the map.
Which brings up a really critical kind of humanizing data point for anyone listening. The juniors strongly believed they were building that map.
Oh, yes.
Their self-reported satisfaction shot up by 1.48 standard deviations. That is the largest self-reported effect in the entire study. They felt like highly productive rock stars.
But the unassisted test proved that feeling was a total illusion.
Exactly. And that gap between feeling highly productive and actually building human competence is such a dangerous trap.
Well, and if you want to know why they fell into that trap, we have to look at the time data. On a roughly two-hour drafting task, the juniors saved about 18 minutes.
So they used it to finish faster.
Right. The seniors did not speed up at all. In fact, on the redlining task, the seniors who had been using AI spent longer doing the work.
Because they were investing time, not just saving it. And I think this connects perfectly to the final two background sources we brought today, because there's this theory that AI actually harms novices.
Yeah, the harm theory. There's a 2025 paper by Bastani and colleagues looking at high schoolers. When they used unrestricted GPT-4, they did great on practice problems, but they did significantly worse on unassisted exams afterward.
Right. The AI did the thinking, so they didn't learn.
Exactly. But when they used a tutor model that withheld the answers and forced them to think, the harm disappeared. And then there's a 2026 paper by Shen and Tamkin at Anthropic. They showed developers using AI to learn a new coding library actually scored worse on
conceptual debugging later on.
So both found harm among novices. Does this new patent lawyer result break those studies or does it confirm them?
It actually synthesizes them really well. It confirms that novices or in this case, juniors who save time but don't deeply engage, they can suffer a learning penalty. But it shows that harm is not the average story for seasoned professionals.
Seniors got better.
Because learning from AI depends entirely on whether you already have the foundational expertise to engage critically with it.
Exactly. The authors suggest that time on task is the core mechanism here. They actually point to a study of Chinese secondary school students where exam skills fell specifically because the students' overall study time dropped. If you spent less time wrestling
with the problem, you learn less.
OK, so before we just accept this as absolute truth, let's talk robustness, because this is a huge claim. Did they stress test this?
Oh, heavily. They ran permutation tests to make sure it wasn't a statistical fluke. They varied the definition of a senior lawyer from three years all the way up to nine years, and the results held.
I saw they even dropped the largest firm from the data completely just to make sure one outlier wasn't skewing everything.
Yep. And they even had a Gemini 2.5 flash model rate the work.
Oh, AI greeting the humans. How did that go?
Well, it agreed on the overall direction. that seniors improved and juniors didn't. It did inflate the effect sizes a bit and correlated somewhat weakly with the specific scores from the human experts, but the core finding was the same.
But wait, what about cheating? Like if I'm a lawyer and I'm used to this amazing inflow tool, I might just secretly pull it up on my other monitor for the unassisted test.
Very real concern. So the researchers did a forensic audit using Notebook LM to check that the lawyers cheated on the no AI redlining task.
And did they?
Well, the audit flagged 15 out of the 91 final red lines for possible AI use.
Wow, 15.
Yeah, but here's the key. Even when they statistically controlled for those flag cases, the core findings absolutely held up.
Okay, that's solid. But we should be honest with the listener about the limits here.
Definitely.
This was a pretty small sample. 91 people completed the full protocol. The firms were heavily selected through a sophisticated client, Google. The experiment was funded by Google. It used a Google tool and had mostly Google co-authors.
All right. There's a lot of Google in there. Also, the partner firms absolutely refused to do a baseline skills test.
Oh, they didn't want to take a pop quiz.
Nobody likes a pop quiz.
Yeah.
So the skill gains had to be inferred purely from the randomization rather than tracking individual growth. And honestly, three months is a very short time in a professional career. We don't really know if that junior bifurcation will fan out into like massive
inequality over a five year apprenticeship.
So what does this all mean? If we synthesize this deep dive, AI is obviously a phenomenal tool for output. It levels the playing field while you're actively using it. But for building long-term internalized expertise, it seems like AI only acts as a teacher if
you already have a deep foundation of knowledge to stand on.
Yeah, and if we zoom out to the macro level, looking at the labor market and higher education, there's a huge question here. If AI is now doing all the grunt drafting work that used to be the training ground for the juniors, Where does the next generation of seniors come from? Firms and
schools are going to have to decide if they should design AI workflows around actual skill formation rather than just maximizing immediate output.
Yeah, and thank you so much for joining us on this deep dive today. I want to leave you, the listener, with one final provocative thought to mull over. If AI completely replaces the tedious, you know, training wheels phase of our careers, we might actually have to
invent entirely new artificial forms of friction just to force the human brain to learn. Are we moving toward a future where doing things the hard way becomes this luxury training perk reserved only for future executives? Something to think about.